viens suis-moi je connais une route des
mailles qui mène au pays de perles et de
corail
je suis un bébé requin
au ventre plat dans la craie
dans les eaux chauds de jeux
d'entraînerai et sans que tu le saches
avec amour avec douceur
moi je lis bébé requin je vais te
dévorer le cœur
[Musique]
viens jouer
jouir à ce moment sur les vagues je vais
te faire descendre dans un ciel de sable
je suis un bébé requin
on ventre blanc dans la craie dans les
eaux chauds de jeux d'entraînerai et
sans que tu le saches avec amour avec
douceur
[Musique]
moi je lis bébé requin je vais te
dévorer le cœur bébé regarde
bébé d'amour
garder moi je me battrai contre mes
sœurs je veux être la seule à te manger
les cœurs
je suis un bébé requin
on va trop blanc dans la craie
dans les eaux chaudes je t'entraînerai
et sans que tu le saches avec amour avec
douceur
moi je lis bébé requin je vais te
dévorer le gars
[Musique]